les amis on parle évidemment d'alain
delon qui est honneurs au festival de
cannes
il devrait recevoir une palme d'or
d'honneur pour l'ensemble de sa carrière
une distinction qui fait évidemment
polémique puisque une pétition a été
lancée à son encontre prochain l'acteur
d'être raciste on va dire oui homophobes
totalement homophobe misogyne d'avoir un
million l'a vu ses enfants dans des
cages à chiendent un jour un destin
bref est ce qu'on peut donner une palme
d'honneur à quelqu'un qui grosso modo
est raciste homophobe misogyne et dont
les enfants sont totalement à la dérive
en du tout et n'importe quoi battles et
guillaume pour la parole parce
qu'évidemment il va donc la question
était pour ou contre le don doit-on
annulé doit-on annulé la palme d'honneur
réponse de guillaume non pourquoi
et qu'est ce que c'est cette ligue de
vertu faites par une journaliste
américaine car un blog qui est pour le
féminisme et les femmes à hollywood
c'est très très bien ok est-ce qu'elle
ait plainte parce que des plaintes
contre alain delon ok alors moi les mecs
2 les enfants qui vivent les a pas de
salon les ligues de vertu la bonne
morale la bien pensante qui sont ces
gens pour dit ça on lui remet pas repris
de virtual iron man palme d'or mais
guillaume alors la part d'ombré causé la
départ dont j'ai même essayé que ces
gens balayent devant leur porte
mais guillaume ce qui est surréaliste
quand tu dis donc s'occuper des gens
bonnes vertus l'homophobie c'est la
bonne vertus leur assise s'éloigne vers
tu le paies le para le passé anthony
delon est homosexuel il l'a jamais
prendre un exemple
et puis arrêtez de me dire en permanence
sièges mais hier c'est le chroniqueur
arrêté de me dire en permanence
il faut séparer l'acteur de l'homme
c'est comme si on m'avait dit à l'époque
pardon je prends un exemple extrême rien
à voir avec de longs c'est comme si on
m'avait dit hitler alors c'est mauvais
mais dans l'amour chez lui avant celle
des mauvaises idées
on ne sépare pas les idées des gens il
est homophobe il est monsieur mathieu si
l'avocat d'alain delon fontan ce que
vous venez de dire je vais vous dire que
là qui prend son pied on n'est pas sûr
de revenir les semaines à venir parce
que vous dites il est raciste
vous dites qu'il est homophobes à bon
quand il rencontre des lilas il a été
condamné qui est le même des plaintes
sur assist rien mais absolument rien aux
beaufs fab goûter ses meilleurs amis
visconti alliés installateurs via liens
utiles aux gens qu'on peut dire des
conneries comme des faucons ont beaucoup
ri qui sait les idées ça alors
rivés sur le mariage mais il a dit qu'il
était content l'adoption pour les
couples homosexuels
il a le droit bon c'est son avis alors
une fois la paix n'est pas une seule
fois il a tenu des propos racistes rien
et dont il ya un moment bondi vers
talansky faut arrêter mais rien qui n'a
rien dit rien quand tu penses qu'il fait
annuler la teneur
oui moi je pense qu'il faut annuler
n'avait pas le donneur aujourd'hui ce
mec là voilà il n'est pas hyper correct
on apprend plein de trucs avec ses
enfants etc
à un moment va pas mettre en lumière
alain delon désolé j'ai pas mal c'est
comme ça ni rien lesquels sont
envisagées mais bien que pour paraître
jeune mathias y en avait qu'un il a mis
ses enfants dans une qui juge le soin
est ce que ça suffit pour un nul et non
pas meneur il a nourri son enfant dans
une cage avec un chien une fois en 72
s'est pas cet ancien principal donneur
alors attendez c'est pas ce n'est pas le
peuple qui donne la qui donne la teneur
c'est le cinéma
s'il a fait du cinéma il a fait marcher
l'industrie du cinéma en récompense pour
le cinéma et c'est pas le pape qui
absoudra odieux mais ma rigueur qu'il a
su tracer les photos c'est vraiment il
faut viser pile langue du cinéma faux
pas c'est pas c'est pas les palmes
académiques que c'est pas une légion
d'honneur c'est les palmes de la palme
d'honneur du festival des graines ont
quasiment donc alors oui mme danielle
sébastien et moi je me lève et je le
sais vous à mon client d'avoir pas la
moindre condamnation juste de la
franchise
si on annulait la pale de nos donneurs
d'alain delon ce serait la palme du
déshonneur pour la france pays de
liberté d'expression en rendant hommage
à de longs sévices conquis rené clément
joseph le terrain hors le festival de
cannes célèbre le cinéma alain delon il
ya toute sa place
voilà il en est
[Applaudissements]
3-2 à arrêter avec ce côté arrêté que ce
côté le pays de la liberté on avait la
liberté d'expression quand c'est pour
dire des conneries shippagan jeudi
encore juste deux mots parce que je veux
que vous êtes à fond sur ce sujet faut
qu'on passe sur d'autres
seb et dark vador comment habiller
l'ariel moi c'est comme à l'habiller
c'est en dehors de ça c'est quand même
louis sa part d'une blogueuse américaine
qui n'a rien dit en ont 25 ans cdt
pourquoi l'ipad joignent donc les
américains ils peuvent critiquer ils ont
laissé faire à hollywood et et dans ces
cas là pourquoi on accepte lars von
trier qui est un fan dit claire où
polanski
oui qui a dit qu'il était fan mystère où
polanski qui lui a été pour le coup
accusé de viol sur une mineure de 13 ans
donc là c'est des choses qui apprécie
alors tu m'as dit non non on ne peut pas
dit ça donne à voir ben oui c'est à dire
de dire que alain delon en dehors on
doit on doit lever 2 à radès alors que
polanski et lars von thurn reconnaît
quand même toi même tu en as parlé la
semaine dernière évidemment qui a pas
d'accusation de racisme mais je dis bien
quand même dit que c'était un très bon
ami de le pen jeudi jour là le solaire
sur l' affaire markovic hybride à elle
ne reconnaissait que io kay ap train de
prouver mais il est des casseroles ce
garçon salaires des casseroles bon alors
là dernier mot magali c'était puis après
faut qu'on passe à voir maman vise ne
vous mêlez jamais des histoires de
familles des autres parce qu'on sait pas
ce qui se passe
il ya eu un reportage et depuis le gars
se fait lyncher
c'est pas normal je suis désolé les
seuls qui peuvent reprocher quelque
chose à alain delon ce sont ses enfants
et sa famille et c'est pas moi je suis
pas léger
warid non parce que il a encore eu
quelque chose au cinéma français et
c'est un mutant c'est un site encore
d'un colosse oui à mi temps dans le
super g pas ça veut dire c'est un combat
gagné mon prêtre union peut faire dans
le public on se met de la vie on a un
regard son île privée des gens je
regrette quand c'est un homme public
c'est ce qu'on fait à ce point là j'ai
souvenir qu'il aimerait dans une
émission sur france 5 que le mot secte
le mot sexualité était contre nature
merci voilà merci
bah je reprends ton propos d'avant si
vous m'avez suivi non mais ça va quand
même pas ce qui me gêne c'est que par
exemple il ya des politiciens qui ont
repris cette affaire
alors alors pas du coup ils s'en servent
un peu pour faire bien sûr tic les
chiens d'hypothermie
arr etc et ça ça varie mais évidemment
bien évidemment tout est dit qu'est ce
que tu filmes toit de l'hôtel ariana
qu'à quatre pattes sous rachel il est
comme ça quelqu'un quel plan du fait
qu'elle plantu fait aucun couac est
maintenant tu fais mais bon je suis là
didon cheveux gris les amis sondages et
brad ont annulé la palme d'or d'honneur
pour alain delon non cette émission un
but c'est qu'elle informe les gens parce
que les gens ne savent pas tout et grâce
à vous journalistes on informe les gens
mais ça va danser le tartuffe molière
cediv aulas qui veulent emprisonné tout
le monde et vous le premier vous avez
espèce de truc à vouloir condamner tout
le monde en parle a laissé les gens que
j'aime bien le relise et commence par
les lire ma fille